so i have the equation 7 minus 10 over x
is equal to 2 plus 15 over x and so this
isn't the type of equation that you
might think that you're used to solving
but i'll give you a little a few moments
to see if you can solve it on your own
well what we'll see is we can do a quick
multiplication of both sides to actually
simplify this to a form that we are more
used to looking at so what's probably
bothering you because it's bothering me
is these x's that we have in the
denominators right over here we're like
well how do we deal with that well
whenever we see an x in the denominator
the temptation is to multiply it by x
but we can't just multiply one of the
terms by x we have to multiply the
entire side by x
so we could multiply this entire side by
x but we can't just multiply the left
hand side by x we'd also want to
multiply the right hand side by x and so
what will that give us
well we distribute the x
we get x times 7 is 7x and then x times
negative 10 over x well that's just
going to be negative 10.
so you get negative 10 right over there
so the left hand side simplifies to 7x
minus 10.
and then your right hand side once again
distribute the x x times 2
is 2x
x times 15 over x well x times something
over x is just going to be the something
x times 15 over x is just going to be 15
plus 15. so now we've simplified this to
a linear equation we have the variable
on both sides so we just have to do some
of the techniques that we already know
so the first thing that i like to do is
maybe get all my x's on the left hand
side so i want to get rid of this 2x
right over here so i subtract 2x from
the right-hand side
now and i always remind you i can't do
that just to the left just to the
right-hand side if i didn't just to the
right-hand side it wouldn't be an
equality anymore you have to do that to
the left hand side as well
and so we are left with
we are left with let me get that pink
color again
the left hand side 7x 7x 7 of something
minus 2 of something well you're going
to have 5 of that something
minus 10
these two x's negate each other and
you're left with equals 15.
now we can get rid of this negative 10
by adding 10 to both sides and i like
that green color when i do stuff to both
sides
so i can add 10
to both sides and i am left with
5x
these negate each other is equal to
and this is the home stretch you see
where this is going can divide both
sides by 5 and we are left with
x is equal to 5. now let's verify that
this actually worked
so let's go back to the original
equation we have 7
minus 10 over 5.
this needs to be equal to i'm just
taking r5 and substituting it back here
this needs to be equal to 2 plus 15
over 5.
so this is seven minus ten over five
this is just two
needs to be equal to two plus fifteen
over five which is just three so two
plus three
seven minus two is five two plus three
is five five is indeed equal to five and
we are done